I saw a
story just just popped up of a trial in
Glasgow 11 people put on trial for
witchcraft that was the headline really
sensationalist in 2023 people are on
trial for witchcraft but then when they
outlin the actual charges it was Satanic
ritual abuse of children it
was sexual abuse of children and and
forcing children into seances and to use
Ouija boards and it was all it was all
jumbled up together together and
uh it did get me wondering
it hate to bring this up you know in
mixed company but is the weird sex stuff
is is part of it the sex rituals yeah it
is part of it and let's come back again
to the blo thing you you know why they
use virgins in their rituals because
when a virgin woman had sex for the
first time the highman breaks so there's
blood so there is a Covenant there so at
the time that's why they use the virgins
for the rituals because there is a
connection there is a covenant there
this pure there something there with
with that blood that gets the the the
demons and then it gets more power
that's why they also use children they
do in these rituals they do sorry for
being so thinky they they rape children
they they they rape babies because they
believe that there's pure and there's
something there with the blood that is
going to give more power and more access
to the demons for saying that you will
be called conspiracy theorist qanon
that's the new term that they use
whatever it means and they'll say you
you believe that there's this ritual
abuse going on of children and even
babies and I I guess my answer to that
is it's like on the whole witchcraft
issue for all of human
history people have been explicitly
practicing witchcraft like all tribes
all over the
world there are people today who call
themselves witches there are religious
people who oppose
witchcraft there are in this case people
on trial
for witchcraft related crimes that
include all of those crazy wild
conspiracy theories with the little kids
and the horrible stuff the only people
who don't believe in this are a handful
of I guess secularists or materialist
type people and then I guess there's
another group that denies it which is
the people who are maybe engaging in it
or covering it up and they they're just
lying and so but I just don't see how
looking at the evidence of all of
history and even the headlines in a
trial right now going on in Scotland the
testimony of someone who's been very
involved in witchcraft how how anyone
could deny it all all of the evidence
says this
stuff happens and has pretty much always
happened mhm the enemy wants to make
this look like it doesn't exist exist so
we don't do anything about it I had
recently recently I was kind of like
mentoring helping someone that she was
involved in Satanic ritual abuse she was
a woman she was a 65 year old woman and
her testimony is crazy and I was trying
to help her to come out of the mentality
helping her with Deliverance with
healing and she told me some crazy stuff
that they used to do to her and people
will hear her testimony and think like
she's crazy she needs to go to a
psychiatric exactly she needs to be L
but she was sharing specific things
about what she went through and even as
a really young girl how she was raped
how she was involved in these rituals
what they have to make her do when they
Lo her in in in cages with animals to no
that was in the story about what
happened in Glasgow they would lock
these kids in cages and cabinets and
they and they in there with animals
because their main thing is fear they
want to kind of like control their mind
so then one day they can be part of the
cult and continue in fact this woman she
was she became like a high priest
saturnist and um and but she believed in
God since she was young because she had
an encounter with Jesus so she believes
that the whole time the Lord was
protecting her for from those things but
she but she Tau me some crazy stuff and
I'm like I didn't even know those things
were real I wait hold on she she
believed in God had an encounter with
Jesus and then became a high ranking
they were training her got to be a High
um Satanist and you know she she had she
so demons she had encounters she she
went through rape they even killed one
of her babies in in when she got
pregnant as a sacrifice so the crazy the
story is crazy they made her get an
abortion or like after they took the
baby out and they killed him from FR of
her so there there's these things are
real these things are real and I'm like
but but this is why the enemy doesn't
kind of like want to make us think that
this is not real so we don't stand and
we speak about these matters we speak
about these things and what are we going
to do against that because if the church
doesn't know that this is real the
church is just going to be sitting my
question then I think I know the answer
but what kind of groups are doing this
meaning is it just some weirdo Fringe
eccentric people on the on the edges of
society who are engaging in this and who
get caught up in it and it's it's
horrible and tragic but it's some pretty
weird out there people or is it
mainstream people and wealthy people and
powerful people and I I you seem to be
implying it's the lad so conspir see
there is again I guess people are going
to think yeah but um I believe there's
so many people in power involved in
Satanism you cannot imagine she even I
mean I don't want to know say her name
because she she's quite private but she
told me when she was super involved in
that that there were people of of of
high rank with a lot of money involved
in these rituals yeah involved in these
practices and she didn't give me names
but she said like that she saw a lot of
people with money in power in government
um involved in this type of practices so
I believe that there's a lot of people
there's normal people doing it and
there's also people in power involved in
this I did hear from someone once this
was someone I knew a little bit in
school like freshman year and then we
kind of lost touch when our separate
ways I don't I don't think he likes me
very much you know very conservative and
but he reached out to me years later
after we had graduated and uh I without
going too much into detail in this cuz I
don't I don't want to be gossiping or
anything it he got involved he just told
me all this once just right over the
phone haven't talked to this guy in
years he got involved in all of this
kind of
stuff like down to the very worst levels
of it and he said there there were very
very wealthy influential power people
and like not you know not very wealthy
like they have nice houses in the
suburbs like like private jet kind of
money you know in involved in this and I
I've heard it so that was a I guess a
direct witness or participant I heard
this from and I've heard it from other
people too but it just on the one hand
it seems like common sense because it's
right there in the
Bible we the principalities and the
powers and the spiritual wickedness and
of high places and the Notions that the
devil is the prince of this world it's
right there and yet you just even I
still today cannot believe that that is
real
because I just expect things to be kind
of more
normal maybe that is normal it may maybe
the abnormal is normal in this world
exactly there you go so yeah it's
exactly like that we call normal what is
non normal
and then the things that are AB normal
those are the normal things so there
there's been talk recently or more
attention paid to some of this ritual
abuse and the abuse of children and
trafficking and and all of that it was a
movie sound of freedom and there's been
some attention paid to this which uh I
loved when the sound of Freedom movie
came out the liberal media said this is
a
qanon conspiracy movie or something I
said wait a sec it's based on the true
story of Tim Balor I I interviewed the
guy who these these are real events so
if you're saying that these real events
are conspiracy theories and what are you
saying about the so-called conspiracy
theories but there's attention paid to
that how does one stop that how do how
was one break up all of these wealthy
Elite cabals of
satanists oh that's good that's
spiritual warer of high rank not
everyone should be involved in that um I
believe that's why we have to prepare
ourselves I believe there has to be a
spiritual preparation and with that I
mean Holiness making sure that you are
like living the holy life that you fast
that you pray that you intercede you're
connected with the holy spirit that you
are closing portals in your life that
you if you have SE in your life you stop
then if you have courses you're breaking
generational courses and iniquities as
the Bible says that you have this this
this this training and that you are
trained as a soldier I always see I
always see
everything for me everything that
happens in the natural is a
representation of how what is happening
in the spiritual realm right right so
part of what I see here with the armies
right how they get trained how they get
equipped they don't go to attack the
enemy they first investigate who is the
enemy who is the head what is the
weakest Point how we can enter the same
way should be for us we just don't
engage in Warfare for the sake of I cast
out this principal no we actually need
to have understanding who is the person
and the principality that we are facing
who is the spirit of high rank and the
same thing fasting prayer cloo close
importance breaking courses and train
also in what waking up early to pray
like this these people train they wake
up early they train they eat healthy
same way for us we don't realize but
even eating certain things affect the
spiritual realm so we are eating all we
eat is Fast Food and Pizza all of the
I'm I'm telling you all of those things
affect the spiritual realm because you
might go to sleep and in the Spirit
right now you might have nightmares now
you cannot perceive maybe the holy
spirit is trying to give you a dream of
something so all of those things for me
are like important that we actually
understand and we actually trained as
the people in the military here here on
Earth so we can actually be part of
God's Army and part of the occupying
Army so we can understand okay how are
we going to occupy Nations is not
actually going against the person
because Ephesians 612 says our fight is
not against flesh and blood but against
principalities against the powers so
understanding that we love the person
but we come against the spirit that's
coming behind and this is what we have
to be prepared for this is what we have
to be ready for if we want to see
actually a change in our nation and
establish the government of Jesus Christ
in that Nation I love the imagery of the
soldier because one of one of my
favorite books on this question is the
spiritual combat by Dom Lorenzo scoy and
he writes about these spiritual
disciplines and and very practical ways
this a 500y old book but very practical
ways to deal with this Vice or that sin
or this temptation When you mention the
food maybe you feel a little sluggish
you have nightmares you don't sleep well
I find the greatest predictor of
of my likelihood my inclination towards
sin and temptation is if I'm tired if
I'm well rested I'm generally pretty
good if I'm really tired I haven't slept
in a few days I've been overworked I was
out late the night before my temptation
to sin even if it's just a mental sin
even if it's just entertaining wrath or
lust or Pride or anything is is far
heightened basic stuff just get get a
good night's sleep you know like a like
a soldier a soldier going out to to a
battle if if he hasn't slept in a few
days he's not going to be as effective
as he would
otherwise and I love this idea of be
wise as a serpent innocent as a dove you
know you don't just go out and say here
we go I'm going to I'm just going to
take on all the bad
forces physical and metaphysical today
no you've got to be a little clever and
you've got to have strategy and you've
got toly that's what I tell people that
the same thing that the people of Israel
when they used to go to war they used to
ask the Lord shall we go is this our
time when they didn't ask God if they
should go to war they they used to lose
they used to go into captivity they you
the same thing happens in the spiritual
realm you're entering into a fight or a
battle that the Lord is not telling you
to enter you're going to suffer counter
attacks because the Lord hasn't give you
the go ahead to go for it so for I said
I always said this for every battle that
you are facing now on Earth there is a
spiritual strategy that you should be
asking the Lord to give you to fight
that and and the focus on how how are we
going to stop all this public evil first
step is Holy your personal Hing starts
in you